no never i'm on team crabs for a life
even though it's skipping theaters and
going straight to streaming we couldn't
be more excited about the spongebob
movie
sponge on the run our animated friends
might look a little bit different thanks
to stylized cgi
but many of our favorite voice actors
will be reprising their roles from the
show
we'll fill you in on who's who including
all new characters and where you might
have heard certain stars before
snoop dogg there's fast cars flashbacks
snoop dogg
obviously having snoop dogg joined the
cast of sponge on the run is exciting
but which denizen of bikini bottom will
this legendary performer be lending his
voice to
well rather than using his iconic voice
on an animated character
it seems as though snoop dogg will be
making a cameo as himself
really snoop is such an intimidable star
that it makes sense he's portraying
himself
in this movie we'll see him laying real
low all the way at the bottom of the
scene
keanu reeves since counter reef is
constantly adding entries to his imdb
page
it's not a total surprise that he's one
of the many voice actors and sponge on
the run
but that doesn't mean we're any less
excited to see him especially since we
have fond memories of his
semi-autobiographical role
as duke kaboom in toy story duke kaboom
canada's greatest stunt man oh yeah okay
so he's not the greatest stuntman but he
is a canadian motorcycle enthusiast
in spongebob on the run he'll be
challenging his sage wisdom by playing
a a piece of stage call me sage good
night a made out of sage and i am a sage
so it works out pretty well spongebob
and patrick will undoubtedly need some
help tracking down gary
and it looks like hianu will be there to
help guide them on their quest
aquafina most of us probably know
aquafina thanks to her musical career
but this green tea singer also has an
impressive acting career
my parents did not name me aquafina yes
she was in the hit film
crazy rich asians as well as jumanji the
next level
and ocean's eight just to name a few now
aquafina will be lending her voice to
sponge on the run
in an undisclosed role we'll just have
to wait and see if we can recognize her
voice
out of a presumably new character reggie
watts
another sponge on the run voice actor in
an undisclosed role is the
multi-talented self-described
disinformationist reggie watts and the
important thing to remember is that this
simulation is a good one
in addition to its comedy and musical
careers he also lent his voice to
pastry pete on tuka and birdie stay in
there
really breathe it in and asif on my
entire high school sinking into the sea
do you think you'll be able to recognize
his voice when you hear it and sponge on
the run
matt berry matt berry isn't a regular
cast member on spongebob squarepants but
this isn't the first time dipping his
toes into the franchise
he also provided the voice for bubbles
the dolphin and spunged out of water
would you mind keeping an eye on this
but this time he'll be playing the
prestigious role of king poseidon a
character we don't know much about yet
we've seen king neptune on the show and
as you mythology fans may know
neptune is the roman god of the sea
while poseidon is a greek counterpart
it'll be interesting to see what exactly
these two characters have in common
jack gore spongebob did promise us
flashbacks in the super bowl commercial
for
sponge on the run so it's not totally
surprising that we're going to see
younger versions of some of our favorite
characters
young patrick star will be played by
jack gore who's known for his work as
timmy cleary on abc's the kids are all
right
sing a song let the world sing along
tom mcgrath if you're a fan of the
madagascar movies then you might
recognize the voice of tom mcgrath
if you watch this you may explode with
excitement
he played the part of skipper the
mischievous penguin and co-directed the
films
and now he's going to be part of sponge
on the run as the appropriately named
light bulb bopped he may look like a
pile of parts but he acts as spongebob's
boat driver
which is probably for the best
considering spongebob's driving skills
he could have invested in a robot
earlier and saved poor mrs puff
a ton of trouble stop i'm going to lose
my teacher's license
tom kinney if you're a fan of spongebob
squarepants then you've probably heard
of the legendary voice actor
tom kinney i'm known for doing spongebob
squarepants
his snell gary and the narrator who says
two hours later
i was lay down he's been working as our
favorite sea sponge since day one
in addition to some other high profile
gigs tom is the voice of the ice king
from adventure time
the narrator and mayor from the
powerpuff girls and the dog and cat dog
according to tom his first big break was
as heifer on rocko's modern life
which is how he met steven hillenburg
who would go on to create spongebob
squarepants
apparently once steven heard tom's voice
he knew he'd found his spongebob
as well as his pet snail the narrator it
just wouldn't be a spongebob movie
without tom kinney
jason maybaum we know it's hard to
imagine but squidward tentacles wasn't
born a grumpy adult
there was a time when he was a child and
actor jason maybaum
will be providing the voice for young
squidward and sponge on the run
you might have seen him as levi on the
show's ravens home
no i'm not i'm a model student aren't
you right antonio raoul
corbo and let's round out our look at
younger versions of our favorite
spongebob characters by talking about
young spongebob squarepants himself
steven hillenberg has joked that this
character ages in sponge years
so we're not sure how old he'll really
be in these flashbacks
but we do know that his voice will be
provided by antonio raul corbeau
who plays nikolaj on brooklyn nine-nine
hi jake i love you
nice to meet you mr hanukkah bill
foggerbach now that we've had a look at
some of the younger cast members let's
move on to some classic voices from the
original series
where would spongebob be without the
help of his trusty best friend patrick
starr
friends don't let friends go on
dangerous quests
patrick is voiced by bill foggerbach who
will be reprising the role for sponge on
the run
in addition to his long-running voice
acting gig he's also known for playing
michael dabber dabinski on the classic
sitcom
coach i may be unusually flumuxed he's
been portraying patrick for over two
decades and says he's grown attached to
this particular sea star over the years
he's close with the rest of the cast so
reprising the rule of sponge on the run
was a no-brainer for bill
veronica ellicino one of the many
mysterious entries on the movie's imdb
page is veronica allesino
who's listed as an unknown voice but
what we do know about veronica
is that she's married to tim hill who's
worked behind the scenes as a writer on
spongebob squarepants as well as other
films like rocco's modern life
and kenny the shark as for veronica
herself she's had a slew of roles
including marie mama luke
in the mama luke we'll have to wait and
see who she'll be and sponge on the run
roger bumpus is another long-term
denizen of bikini bottom and you might
recognize him as the voice of
spongebob's grumpy neighbor squidward
tentacles
spongebob what are you doing in here
according to roger he loves the
underwater world created by the late
stephen hillenburg
and finds a lot of humor in it unlike
his character squidward
when he first started voice acting in
spongebob squarepants squidward's
voice was much more monotone roger
claims that after everyone discovered
his ability to scream as squidward
they made sure to make his character
upset even more often
clancy brown not only does clancy brown
have a long career as a voice actor
but he's been in some memorable movies
as well he was byron hadley in the shell
shank redemption
35 000 that's what he left me and kieran
in highlander
but in the underwater world of bikini
bottom he's mr krabs well
usually some fans couldn't help but
notice that our favorite money grubbing
crab sounded different in the games
spongebob squarepants battle for bikini
bottom
and battle for bikini bottom rehydrated
that's because mr krabs was voiced by
joe white
instead of clancy brown a difference
that loyal spongebob fans definitely
noticed
but rest assured that clancy will be
back to reprise his famous role in
sponge on the run
mr lawrence give up world domination
give up world domination that's like
giving up show business
douglas lawrence ososki is better known
as mr lawrence and he's been trying to
steal the crappy patty formula for over
two decades with no end in sight
like many other cast members he's also
spent time working on rocco's modern
life both as a writer
and as the voice of philbert not only is
he the voice of plankton but he's also
one of the writers behind spongebob
squarepants
which he says is a lot easier on the
vocal cords than portraying plankton
jill talley and where would plankton be
without his wife
karen plankton look how cute a baby he
is fun fact the character is named after
stephen hillenburg's wife
karen hillenberg and to make things even
more interesting the voice of karen
plankton
jill talley is married to tom kinney the
voice of spongebob
she's worked as karen plankton on the
show and now she's ready to take her
role to the big screen
carolyn lawrence we have seen plenty of
aquatic characters but now let's
celebrate our favorite undersea dwelling
lands mammal
sandy cheeks don't you dare take the
name of texas in vain
she's voiced by carolyn lawrence who's
grown attached to the role over the
years
she loves letting sandy sing even if
carolyn insists she isn't very good at
it
you might also recognize her as cindy
vortex from the jimmy neutron franchise
needless to say caroline is part of the
core cast who will be returning for
sponge on the run
faster than a barefoot jackrabbit on the
hot greasy griddle in the middle of
august
mary jo catlett poor mrs puff has been
trying to teach spongebob how to operate
a boat with no end in sight
oh spongebob why but behind the scenes
mary jo
catlett has been busier than most of us
realized in fact she was discovered by
stephen hillenburg
after he saw her performing on stage and
decided she would be perfect for the
part of mrs puff
she's been in many theatrical
productions including hello dolly and
beauty and the beast mary jo enjoyed her
transition to voice acting so much
she stuck around for over two decades so
far lori allen
hey girl let's hang out since it seems
like the whole cast is getting together
for sponge on the run
mr crabb's daughter pearl the whale will
be there too
she's played by actress lori allen who
also plays diane simmons on family guy
he promised to introduce me to dan
rather but instead he introduced me to
danny bonaducci
including films like toy story 3 and
inside out as well as shows like
futurama and cowan chicken
i'm getting a job today are you excited
to see sponge on the run
even if it won't have a theatrical
release let us know how you'll be
streaming the movie in the comments
section below
don't forget to stay connected with us
here at the things by clicking on the
subscribe button and turning on your
notifications for more new videos
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
you